this is just about more control
house republicans bristled that new
guidance from the capitol physician
wednesday
mandating mask wearing minority leader
kevin mccarthy and many of his fellow
republicans
refused to mask up we are vaccinated
we're not a hot spot
but they're forcing you to wear a mask
not in the senate but in the house this
is just about more control
this after the cdc on tuesday said
vaccinated people
should wear masks indoors in areas of
substantial or high covet 19
transmission due to the increased
transmissibility of the delta variant
a high level aid for house speaker nancy
pelosi said republican opposition was
quote
moronic after a report based off of
garbled audio said
pelosi called mccarthy a [ __ ] pelosi
later downplayed the moment
is kevin mccarthy a [ __ ] and if so why
i said earlier in my comments science
science science and science
to say
[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the show my name is wayne dupree and
we are live
it is our friday or thursday
and we got some lemonade
pelosi is drunk
she said she will now arrest people if
they step foot without a mask
they'll be fined they'd be fine there'd
be a monetary
uh yeah monetary threats of monetary
fines
yeah they've been fighting they've been
fighting congress members
i know one was complaining about it and
congress members have been
losing their arbitrary or their their
fight
to to pay i mean um
like three of them uh not sued but
uh tried to go and say okay
we want to fight this and they lost
their fight so they had to pay 500
when you dance in the end zone of nfl
game don't they find them
no you pull one pull out a sharpie pin
sign your name and throw the football
no that won't just be fine it says here
it says in today's edition of
pelosi's abuse of power capital police
have been directed to
arrest staff and visitors to comply with
her mask mandate
for vaccinated individuals
that'd probably remove they might remove
it staff and visitors they might just be
removing you from the
it says arrest woody i mean i can't i
can't be any more clear with you
listen listen
they just gave the bulletin here it is
you will be arrested on site not just
fine you will be arrested there it is
well i mean if if she wields that kind
of all right
she wields that power right now can you
say hey becky
becky oh i'm like yeah it's karen but oh
no it really is
sorry sorry no
i'm a little feisty ladies jimmy let me
introduce
leah brian and woody we
are we are here um if you have any
questions for us drop them
in the comment section we will answer
your questions
questions y'all uh and keep them
uh as religious as you can thank you
angela angela says hi i love the show
kathy says hi i love the intro oh thank
you dk bliss
dope intro yeah i like it too i like it
too i need to put a little cactus there
that's cute yeah yeah uh cactus
i love you too becky i guess i guess
the question to all of you out there
right now
is and yes xavier is right uh
nancy's power drunk
one of you brought up the
idea that they would probably be a
lockdown could be a lockdown
before october and november am i right
yeah leah said before thanksgiving
okay i say right before thanksgiving
yeah i think it's gonna be closer to
like january
okay both of y'all said that it could be
a lockdown
uh or some kind of some kind of
restricted mandate of
something maybe you might decide the
mask mandate's going to come back i'm
sure
it already has for indoors for uh
whether it's places that are high
yeah california but it's it's we're
gonna see mass mandates come back i
don't see
i don't i don't believe we'll see
another lockdown i don't i just don't
think it'll happen
michael okay so then the unvaccinate if
that's the case then that means it
shouldn't be that bad right
no i i mean i don't believe that they're
going to risk another lockdown
i think politically that nobody wants to
risk on lockdown
i don't think it'll matter so much or is
it just because the death rate won't be
that high
you know i i think it's like now well we
see when we see hospitals fill up to the
point
where there's not room you might have
like you might see it like on a small
scale to like
localize to cities we're not going to
see a massive
walk down like we saw before just now
because the death rate's too low
if this was a real true pandemic and
everybody there was a three percent
death rate we would see lockdown
if it wasn't made so political maybe you
would but
it's completely political now we're
gonna be rolling up into another
uh what the midterm elections in in 2024
right hospitals were so full that nurses
were on the tick tocks doing tick-tock
dances
yeah maybe those days will come back now
i mean there's lots of hospitals that
are full though i mean they're not in
fault yeah
my argument was how many hospitals have
you been to and walking around
you're basing it off of you saw a couple
nurses and tick tock videos
that there can't be but there can be
hospital rooms full of people
but that is a very high possibility that
maybe some areas of the hospital have
less work because they're not dealing
with intensive care patients and the
hospitals are slowing down the rates
of what they're what they're bringing
people into hospitals for right
maybe you also have sections of the
hospital that don't have people full
but they're not icu nurses do you see it
what might you see what my point was
if you're saying there's not gonna be
lockdowns it means it's because there's
not gonna be a lot of debts because if
people
are dropping dead everywhere there's
going to be less there's going to be
less
now because you have more people that
are vaccinated you have more people that
have natural immunity
naturally i mean you have you have i
didn't forget it
you have more people that have two you
have more people that have
two possible ways to have some sort of
immune build up
so you're going to have less people
dying that should happen i mean that's
again it's refreshing unless we talk
about a real
a real horror scenario that this was
created in a lab
it was created to be a bioterror weapon
and then
but again we're not seeing that we're
not seeing that right now these variants
are getting
more contagious and a little less deadly
but that's how most viruses that
naturally are
spread for now in 2020 one
but the reason why i created
this title will americans accept another
lockdown is because i also don't think
they can they can put it in place
they can say or these governments can
say
we are imposing a lockdown i just don't
think the american people
are going to accept it this time like
they did
last year i think there will be a lot of
people
that are i can use the word rebelling
rebelling or protesting or having large
groups of mass protests and and not
staying inside that's why that's why i
said i don't i mean
the american people's not going for that
lockdown crap anymore
no we're gonna have a hard time they're
gonna have a hard time getting people to
wear masks
and dory indoors again even though
they're vaccinated because you took the
lid off
of that can of worms right once once you
let people go
once people are all started doing stuff
again you get that feeling that we've
crossed
that bridge we're already on the other
side you know uh
and it's hard to convince people to go
back
so when nancy pelosi says science
science science
science that's all i believe in science
uh science is the numbers i mean it
really is truly the hardcore
to the numbers and when you look at my
county county of
hamilton county of ohio 800 000 people
live here
10 percent got the cove at 80 000 got
the kovid
and 1300 died when you look at the
entire county
of those that got it those that survived
and those that live here it's point
zero zero one six percent
death that's crazy that's not a pandemic
and that's science yeah but again
population population sciences
not that is and again if you're in new
york city it's a little bit different
well population population population
density has something to do with it
but but that also has to do with the
main causes
cuomo man made that he
i think that again the issue of issues
with nursing homes that's another issue
but you have population density is
another issue one of the reasons why it
spreads faster in cities
so if you live in a i'm from a rural
county i lived in atlanta right
when i was in atlanta when i'm in
atlanta i take it a lot more
seriously than i do absolutely numbers
across the board
you have to because there's more people
there's nobody near me but can we just
can we just say this what if we just
leave the government out of it
and we just say you either get the
vaccine or not wear your max
mask or not and you may die and you may
overload our hospitals
and then because if you overload the
hospitals how fair is that somebody goes
in with a heart attack
it's not fair how fair was that that
they
nobody was going to the hospitals on the
lockdown and people were
no no people were dying because their
normal checkups or their normal things
they scared the hell out of everybody
and people didn't go to the hospitals
that needed to go
couldn't get appointments really that's
a bad thing that doesn't change
you're both missing my point my point is
this virus is not going anywhere this is
what a normal virus does hold on
it's going to be with us forever it's
not going to be eradicated
it may get as weak as the flu one as the
cold one day but we're not going to
eradicate this
we have to learn to live with it if we
are going to be in hysteria every time
there's a new variant because we are
afraid the sky is falling
and and we freak out like chicken little
because we're afraid our hospitals are
going to get overwhelmed
we've got a major major issue we cannot
continue to go down this road
we are hurting more than what we are
helping what we have to figure out is a
therapeutic that will get us through
this at home
instead of just getting our noses
swabbed and them telling us you have
covered now go home and wait to see if
you'll die
and then come back in if you need a
ventilator
we got to stop that a five-day
therapeutic we have to get better you
say science is always moving science is
always rolling
we need a therapeutic that will help us
through this with or without the vaccine
because what are you going to do and
three more mutations
whenever the virus mutates and it
doesn't help the vaccine whatsoever
we're back to square one how do you get
people to trust where one how do you
guys
do you get people to trust the new
therapeutic if they're not willing to
trust the vaccine now
because it's completely different raise
your hand to an audience if you're
willing to take hyphen
is not because of americans because a
therapeutic is completely different than
ever
is not a vaccine acting is not a vaccine
well i have a problem with um
with the leaders as many of many of our
audience do
uh because the leaders don't know you
have politicians trying to be medical
experts
yeah you have you have the media trying
to be medical experts
first off the media can't even do their
job with journalism but they're
but you know they're trying to be
journalists and then you have the
doctors
who are supposed to be experts
in medical in the medical field
but they're trying to be political and
they're
trying to be political well no uh
misinformation surrounding face masks
can you
discuss that the masks are important
for someone who's infected to prevent
them from infecting someone else
now when you see people and look at the
films in
china and south korea whatever
everybody's wearing a mask
right now in the united states people
should not be walking around
with masks you're sure of it because
people are listening really no
closely to this right now people should
not be white there's no reason to be
walking around with a mask
when you're in the middle of an
now yeah i know that that
somebody said somebody told me that that
was fouchy from last year but
right and the violence has changed it's
gotten worse yeah again science
science is the method
but the people in the white house but
the people in the white house last year
certain generals saying to mask up okay
but factory would say don't miss i'm
going back to what i said before you
have so much confusion at the top
that that's why a whole lot of people
democrats republicans independents
libertarians green party whatever
whatever the hell
non-party that's why they don't want the
vaccine
because nobody i mean because their
common sense is really kicking in
and they're saying you know what if they
don't know why am i gonna stick
something in
in my arm that oh wait ding
on my phone somebody just died of
covet after getting the vaccine ding oh
another person just died of covet after
getting the vaccine
90 97 for the 97 of people dying though
of covid right now
don't have the vaccine 97 percent
what's the percentage of people dying
from the vaccine
itself it's larger than anything from
the number
from the number we've ever given out
from the number of people who've gotten
the vaccine
we just you said about your sciences
they're dying yeah dying related to
the vaccine not to covet yeah based off
the number of people have gotten the
vaccine
you're talking about point zero zero
zero zero ten thousand people have died
according to the cdc
did you just tell me or did you not just
tell me the ten zero zero but i can
avoid the fact that science says that i
get
we're talking less than a fraction of a
percent i'm talking about the covet if
you get it
you're more likely to survive it as long
as you can
get the vaccine you could die from it as
long as i've been alive
right as long as you have to right as
long as wayne has been alive
i have never seen so many people
talk about the point point point point
of something in
in either way as
as a as a rallying cry
because it was happening last year too
the point point
point point or something i mean so many
arguments over the point point
point something of data but again
it's because the leaders are so are
delivering confused information no
there isn't one expert that somebody
could really look to
for guidance on this whole thing not
mine
about the point of zero zero one percent
of those in this county
died from covet okay so now you're
saying point one percent or less but in
your counties
die from the vaccine
oh no that is wrong you have a better
note guys
you're both arguing on the greater facts
okay
the vaccine survival rate absolutely so
here's
here's the issue they're still getting
covered
you don't have to talk data you don't
have to talk statistics and you
do not have to talk you don't even have
to talk science when you're talking
about this
just talk for real and it's amazing what
you can get through let me can i just
have the floor for five minutes
well you're not and listen to what i'm
saying will you fly on a plane brian do
you fly on a plane
yeah i've done it okay no just listen i
won't fly on a plane
because i don't want to die but that's
my choice that's my choice
right people without statistics let me
explain how
i know because i've worked on aircraft
so i get that i get that just like
people that have worked on the vaccines
feel like the vaccines are safe
just except for those who say no people
that have worked in covid
says the cove is safe to get let me tell
you how this works out
it works out as a personal choice and
what do i mean by that
which one do you feel like you want to
die from more the vaccine
that you chose or the covid that you got
by no choice
i feel more comfortable with saying i
don't want to pick my own demise so i'm
not going to get the vaccine because
then i will regret getting it
if i know that i'm on my deathbed with a
vaccine if i get
covered i'll be able to say well then it
was my time
it was my right i don't want to have to
choose hmm should i get the vaccine this
might kill me
all day i'll take my chance with coco
and that's how a lot of people feel that
way right up to the ventilator to get
ready to put in
right like look how much and that's fine
but you're not here to save somebody's
life really
i'm not gonna save somebody's life
somebody's life
a lot of people feel that way up until
the point that they're slamming into the
earth
at 21 000 miles an hour with an airplane
okay
i will not get on an airplane because i
how many people died last year in
airplane crashes
almost none stop okay that's not the
marriage i mean but it's but it's not a
fair it's not a human
to apples though it's not an apple i'm
not doing apples apples because i don't
want to play statistics with you
i am staying as a human being let me
choose
how i die and i don't want to have to
pick the vaccine
as part of that choice i would rather
let it be from natural coven
if that's how i'm gonna go i'm not gonna
put something in would you put heroin in
your arm
just for hi no no but again not the same
thing
right i'm not no because i have a chance
to become an addict i have a chance to i
mean there's a whole bunch of
no well it's basically yeah because you
don't want to become an addict
my point is even though there's not a
lot of people
just because there aren't a lot of
people dying from airplane wrecks
doesn't mean i want to get on it it's
not about statistics with me
it's not about um what doctors tell me
it's about how do i want to go because
of a vaccine
i'd rather go because that's what he
would
but you didn't put the number up you
didn't put the number up it's 137
uh wayne yeah i mean that's
you're talking 137 versus 600 000. yeah
they mean like it's just the
600 probably even higher probably
billions 200 257.
does that three point hold on three
point two hundred
three point seven million flights one
crash point per
3.7 million flights yeah you know what
you know you know what you know what let
me let me say this
let me say this for woody and brian
see you're talking about aircraft man
that's i love that no no no no no no i'm
i'm going to talk about these stats now
because stats fly over people's heads
since we're talking about air flight
stats fly
over people's heads especially when uh
people there's a whole lot of people out
there they really don't care about stats
they just care about the realization of
what they see the optics
they see things on tv manipulate it
mind you but they see things on tv they
think it's real
you though you throw the the smallest
percent or something up there
people can't quantify that people can
except for
maybe two or three people that might
follow you or
you know that might talk to you at your
job or whatnot
they excuse me they might understand
that but most people
i remember ben shapiro vince pippel
ben shapiro in the early in the early uh
in the middle 2000s whatnot uh well
12 2012 2013 when i left the democrat
party
um i used to listen to mr perry ben
shapiro
talk about abortions in black community
two point then percent uh something
something something percent and
first off he never even he doesn't hang
in a black community he doesn't drive
through he doesn't
he doesn't walk he doesn't know that
much he read
certain things and then he would go out
and talk what he reads
you take that into the black community
and you talk but
did you know 2.7 percent of a yaw and
and and then the four points i'm but the
zero point something
it doesn't it i mean it's not going to
com
compute until you talk to him you know a
lot of y'all are dying
or you're allowing a whole lot of these
kids to die because of abortions and
y'all got to fix you know why
because you got to fix up this community
and you can't
and and and these abortion clinics and
stuff they are
killing that means a whole lot more when
you can break it down and be a whole lot
more real
data is real you can also be manipulated
by the people in
in in high places but when you talk to
somebody straight true
like cole beasley did bro i'll play his
video in a second
he didn't just he didn't come with
statistics he told he told
he told a story that would had
that you could have optics so you could
understand what he was talking about
okay a lot more people were
more easily convinced over antidote
anecdotal evidence which is things they
see
on a small scale versus you know large
term data i'll agree with that
let me see let me show um let me show
cole because
we were talking about that i wanted to
start this off by saying
i'm not anti or pro-vaxx i'm pro-choice
with that being said the issue at hand
is
information is being withheld from
players in order for a player to be
swayed
in a direction he may not be comfortable
with when dealing with a player's health
and safety there should be complete
transparency regarding information that
is vital
in the decision-making process without
having all the proper information a
player can feel misguided and unsure
about a very personal choice
it makes a player feel unprotected and
gives concerns about future topics
regarding health and our ability to make
educated decisions
with regard to our overall safety we
have to know we are armed with full
knowledge
and understanding that those who are in
a position to help us will always do
that
based on our individual situation some
people may think that i'm being selfish
and making this a me thing
it is all about the young players who
don't have a voice and are reaching out
to me every day because they're being
told if they don't get vaxxed
they'll be cut agents are being told by
teams if they have unvaccinated guys
they will not be given opportunities as
of now to be seen in workouts
so once unbacked players get cut they're
losing a dream they have worked their
whole lives
for over a vaccine that is proven to not
keep people from contracting covet as
we've seen
every doctor i've gone to with questions
begins every sentence with from what we
know now which tells me we don't know
enough
the nflpa is working to have vaccinated
players tested more frequently than what
the nfl
initially stated a lot of players got
the vaccination with the idea that these
rules were already set in stone
and they're not it is common sense that
if a vast or unbacked player is tested
less frequently
the likelihood of a player being pulled
for kobe drops dramatically
in regard to player safety i will
conclude by saying we all want to be
safe
for so many players around the nfl
safety does not solely mean
avoiding the covet virus our health is
the now
and years beyond which we are trying to
protect with our personal choice
while doing all the things we did in our
protocol during a very successful
2020 nfl season
uh that's that's kind of where the issue
has been for me
this whole time and that's how i wanna
you know
and becky said why is he wearing a mask
under his nose because he doesn't want
to wear the masking first please
that's why and i mean it probably
protects the microphone
you know yes
but you know i i mean even for me
uh if i if if the place mandates a mass
i am going to go in there with a mass
but i do also bring it down
under the nose too that's because i'm
like
man i got i gotta wear this okay fine
you're gonna make me where it is
then i'm gonna bring it down right here
you know
nobody ever says anything so whatever
and then
and then i'm out of there great i'll
give you this claim
i will get the vaccine when joe biden
shuts down the southern border and stops
allowing illegals with the
virus to come in did we see ain't never
gonna happen
that's why i was reading i was reading
numbers that were released this is again
this is a little bit older numbers i
think they're
from um when joe biden turns black
you're talking about seven percent of
the people at the southern border
who were being tested on both sides of
the border and the mexican side and the
u.s side
only about seven percent were testing
positive for
guess what woody thirty percent of them
refused the vaccine
seventy percent seventy percent doesn't
matter
remember we're trying to get everybody
all right it doesn't work unless
everybody gets it you're over seventy
percent that's more than texas that's
more than any of the border states
they're next to it doesn't matter
doesn't i mean if you're trying to
vilify them as being the guys who are
spreading
it it 70 is way better than 45 percent
so just like cole said why can't i be
pro-choice
yeah it's so funny i just like the idea
he's like
my favorite
why am i being vilified by being
pro-choice
guys they're going to be vilified but
again
they're calling us the unvaccinated
pandemic now we're being vilified
health care companies are starting to
talk about raising premiums if you don't
have the vaccine why
why would they not i why would they well
for something people who are overweight
seven percent of the people in icu care
are unvaccinated how much more money
does that cost
how about in insurance 99 percent of you
know
100 it's 99 that's not fair to me
because you're talking about this
fraction of the money i have just as
many antibodies
if 97 of the people that are in the
hospital are on that no
no no it's just like they they raise
your your their rates
60 percent yes smoke does your premiums
go up
where your premiums go up that 99 that
is a false number
there's multiple there's multiple
multiple sources
joe in the cdc saying something
different when you
when p i mean again people getting sick
95 of people going to the hospital
percent percent we need to we need to
get rid of that
got their percent entire statistics i
won't do it anymore
96 cents out of every dollar you have
those two
well but you know what i mean like yeah
but 96
cents of each dollar is only 96 people
okay again
okay 96 people 99 of a million 100
if the cost of insuring you goes up
because
it cut you're more likely to get if you
are morbidly obese your insurance can go
up
if you smoke your insurance can go up i
mean things that they see that could
cost them more money
it's a business decision if i can
survive
a disease by 99 survival rate why the
hell would it go up
how much does it cost to put a
ventilation why would it go on 97
percent
ventilation but again i'm still trying
to
i mean i'm you know we can go to the
next subject too
it's just that when people throw
percents out there
i just i mean it's almost like polls i
just
don't that's why i rarely ever talk in
person
well i will say uh maybe
uh eight nine out of ten i'll say nine
out of ten or eight out of ten
i don't say percent but you know you
know i'm
that's how much i don't like percent
because
people use these things
and then you could go on another website
and find something else you go on
another website and find something else
because these things are so manipulated
to for a person's argument i don't
believe
like uh like i'll go back to uh
the unemployment under barack obama i
i mean the percentage of the
unemployment thing kept going down
why should we believe that when people
weren't even being counted
the department of labor will put out
those statistics all the time put out
those percents
and look at the percents that are coming
out now
under biden do you believe the do you
believe he created a certain
percentage of percentage of jobs when
he's handing out free checks and
people are quitting every month the gdp
is
down the gdp percent is down to what
it to what they said that it was
supposed to be
um or what they were looking for these
percentages
are so uh i'm not biased but they're so
manipulated
they have people running and and and
fussing
about the smallest little things that's
why we have to be a whole lot more
real and say but this is what we see
this is what we see somebody in the
comment section just said just a while
ago
in their place they have two hospitals
in
their areas that are full i believe that
there are some hospitals in other areas
that aren't full it's it's
12 million there you go ohio but in
california
the numbers keep going
but that's that's why i don't think
you'll have a lockdown again nationally
again
but you could see it at a local again
l.a county probably right at the verge
where
it's already a cesspool they got the
plague on the streets out in
l.a county and just remember that's true
that's true arguing the point that the
cost of ventilators and the cost of
drugs are so much
uh it's shocking to me if you're a
libertarian
because you should be anti this because
they are proud they are price gouging us
a cost of a prescription drug is a penny
a ventilator
about seventy five dollars okay that's
what they're charging insurance
companies though and what i'm saying is
it's
price gouging and it's disgusting
first thing you do is is you allow um
medicare to negotiate prices oh i get i
get what we have
government the problem is they shouldn't
be raising our rates
when they should be lowering their rates
because everybody from the top is
getting money it's price gouging it's a
whole nother conversation
but the end of the story is no they
shouldn't raise our rates until they
actually charge us the correct rates
that's not going to happen it's a
million dollars and it only took five
dollars to make let's let's be honest
that's not going to happen
it happens in other countries because
they get they again this is one of those
times where the government has it has a
place to do something
to prevent price gouging is something
that the government should do
but they don't they've taken their hands
off the health care system
and if you argue take your hands off the
health care system and don't force
vaccines
exactly you're going to take your hand
off the health care system that's
private
if they want to raise their prices or
not unless you're saying you want the
government to step in and stop them
if private insurance sees that it costs
more for the to cover
somebody who's on balance okay with them
raising your rates if you're a
how the business works is how private
business works yeah they say it costs
them more money but the government
but the government has their hands all
in everything right now
they are leading the charge they are
leading the way
and guess and guess who's happy the
private businesses be good
because because the government right now
is driving everything
they they are for that they basically
all these companies that came out over
the last couple days they're doing it
because the government
is is pushing this thing right right i
mean
are they nervous anymore
forcing people to take a shot
i don't think i'm going to be being
forced to take the show but again i
understand
let me add on to it they're forcing
people to take a shot
or they will lose their job yeah yeah
again they have a right to say this is
where you get back into you you have a
right to say
what you're going to employ somebody for
you have a right to say
i mean that that's there has to be a
lawsuit somewhere in there somewhere
you could do especially when you have
that experience
okay so so with that talking point being
gone just take that out of it all
together
i'm a healthy male never had any real
problems ever in my entire head you had
covered
i had covered why can't you have it
why can't i choose uh you can prove
antibodies why do you have to get the
vaccine for your work
if you can get an antibiotic test and
they show that you have antibodies
why do you have to get a vaccine nobody
can answer that for me
not even dr falchi i haven't asked them
but
uh oh
the thing is they can track they can
track who's been vaccinated or not
that's probably the simplest answer
what i would say to you brian is if if
you are healthy and you feel confident
when i say do your research your
research should be talking to your
doctor
make an appointment talk to your doctor
if he says now you're healthy you're
fine
i'd live with it but he was thinking i
don't even know who
i ain't he a doctor and i can't tell you
how long then just talk to yourself
i'm sure you have again i i think you
talk to your doctor most people most
people
you say if i need a doctor for anything
i'm a wife calling that i don't
i don't do doctors we don't guys don't
do doctors
not normally you're either going to live
or you're it's
like kobe's going to kill you or it's
not right
nbc nbc olympic ratings
nbc olympics ratings have tanked like
a disgrace like we didn't know that
already right
yeah and athletes are being blamed
basically for their wokism
uh the prime time con the primetime
coverage
of the tokyo olympics continues to
spiral
i was uh the mvp of the basketball
champion milwaukee bucks was asking
hey i want to watch the nba i mean
i want to watch um team usa what channel
is it on
you know what i because i haven't
watched the olympics so i don't know
but i'll notice i thought it's all of
y'all right now
i don't think it's on regular tv no
i i don't know i'll be honest i don't
know i don't even have any
favorites i think it's on peacock and
pizza
service right i have no idea how to do
you have to pay for that woody no
free it's free with your well comcast
it's i have comcast that's free with
comcast
okay okay but comcast
comcast numbers are up okay comcast
numbers are up
based on the numbers that just came in
but no
but how can they be uh i think big
events i think some of the big events
like the stuff that they know a lot of
people will watch is being televised on
like
the different um affiliate network like
usa
and and nbc soccer going on my wife was
watching the highlights i think today
netherlands netherlands and the us plays
today i think women's team
no that's normal we're not olympics
the u.s the women's u.s team lost their
first game and then what
tied zero zero the second game yeah
they're not evolving right they're not
looking great
yeah uh no because they weren't you know
why instead of training all year and
focusing on their
their uh mental toughness they decided
to go out and be political you can't do
that
same same thing same thing with the san
antonio
uh spurs head coach for
the for the entire time that donald
trump was in office
greg popovich was outspoken critic
of donald trump his team suffered for
four years
because he couldn't focus on his
team he had to every time that the game
was over
we we have to do something about this
president because you know the
the atmosphere that he is doing for the
country
dude your team and now you can see
the players are now complaining about
the coach
greg popovich yeah they did it blew up
in his face that's because they're
losing though sports is super
competitive and you're gonna have to
blame
somebody i you know the uh uh
popovich popovich his team suffered
because tim duncan retired
and kawhi leonard left um the women's
the women's soccer team i will say
i think they're suffering because it's
in their head a little bit they went two
years without losing the game
and they went they expected to walk into
this and just
walk out with a gold medal right and
then they didn't and then they did
not go into them right they still could
but
it doesn't look and they were unfocused
i mean i saw the uh little
purple head haired girl on um what was
her name megan
she was on ellen and she was even saying
about how she was doing all these
different interviews and stuff like that
which will take away from your game
i mean you're going to the olympics you
need to train full force there's no time
for it
i said i think they got in their own
heads you know i mean i i
good form i don't know that it's it's
it's so much because they're
politically active i think it's because
they think they're the best team
they might be they might they might
still be the best team in the world
but if you don't walk in focus every
other team that's there
is pretty darn good too you know you
could be the best team but
the difference between the best team and
the next best team
isn't real big congress why
oh wait oh you're muted but we're moving
on to the next story
they're physically equal they're
physically equal but it's who wants it
the most
yeah i mean there's a lot of that
there's a ton of that in sports the
basketball
in men's basketball it's gone that way a
little bit too where the other countries
have caught up to the us
but they also play as a team athlete
wise athlete to athlete-wise they're not
the same
but they play the team year-round
somebody in the chat wants to know how
we feel about simone i don't care
i could care less what she does it's no
different than me saying i need to take
a break from work
i don't care what she does if she is
mentally unfit to do her job then she's
mentally unfit
yeah what's the one who said he's the
one that said we're not here to win gold
medals for people
i don't know i think it was mobile
but i don't i don't care what she does
she's 19. she's probably going to regret
it as she gets older because maybe she
had another chance to perform in the
somebody said that they they
got contracts with nike already already
yeah yeah
million dollar contracts yeah yeah
greatest athlete olympic athlete of all
time she disappointed a lot of people
she disappointed a lot of little kids
that wanted to see her that looked up to
her
um and now they they probably
are questioning their own mental health
at eight years old but again if if she
didn't feel
mentally raped ready to do that you're
talking about a sport that you could i
don't care
whatever your career is
greatest olympic athlete of all time
look she's the first person they ever
told that they won't score her full
points for what she does because she
does
that's because there will be
really they've told her that she doesn't
get the same scores
what she did the stuff she does is at a
higher level complication
than what the other athletes can perform
and if they try to do it they might get
hurt
unless she doesn't get scored the same
way i mean
i'm trying to hear woody for the first
time i've never heard this before that's
fascinating if that really is true and
i'm taking your word for it
if that's true that's fascinating that
that
she's that's that played into the reason
why she did this
i would have done the same thing if they
told me that they weren't going to score
me on my talents and then they were only
going to score me on my creativity
because i'm better than everybody else
you're darn right i'm going to take a
stand against the olympic wilderness
and say fine i'm quitting and i'm
probably just going to make it up that
it's my mental health
that was the only justification she
could get out of it she basically gave
the olympics the middle finger
because they didn't screw over the
scoring tom brady only gets five points
per touchdown because he's won so many
super bowls
you know i mean yeah he is the greatest
he is the greatest football player of
all time though but
exactly what he said it would be like
tom brady only gets half tom brady
no he's not oh town breakers but you
know that's
michael michael jordan only gets one
point perfect
behind her why not why not say oh i'm
too good
well then let's see how your ratings
hurt whenever i don't compete yeah and
that's what she did i don't think that
she's mentally suffering because she's
scared of the stress
i think she's kicked off at the olympics
and this is her way saying screw you
i mean she also kind of stuff though
she's a she's a sexual assault survivor
a lot of people have been assaulted and
they just don't bring it up they don't
talk about it
they get on with life instead of growing
up to be an older person
they still have karen they felt that
nothing to do with that you really think
she got the olympics and went oh
somebody touched me so now i can't do
flips no
no she could have she couldn't she could
have
she could have anxiety due to that she
could have been dealing with anxiety for
a long time and then they tell her
then they tell her flat out that we're
not going to score you correctly you
know it's time to deal with it we can
keep
it's a trigger moment it's a trigger
yeah i mean it's
possible all right get uh
questions please questions here in the
chat
for me woody bryan leah
uh oh okay we're gonna have a fun
question
section it could be fun i mean
what questions do you have for us
anything goes
anything gold you got to keep it keep it
it's free well i mean we don't have to
read it right now we don't have to
play it we can delete it well i'm saying
that for
for anybody that's in this group here
that wants to read anything off the
board
i don't know i don't know theresa
theresa says woody she's been doing this
for a long time making up excuses
no i mean again she could have been
having a tough time again i think the
biggest issue might have been
that if you're just flat out told you're
not gonna be scored for what you do
why would you want to if that's true i
agree with their hundred percent i'd
walk out of the damn thing too
that's horrible i wouldn't have went
for true yeah i mean i would be like you
know
and honestly that would have caught
cause a bigger stir
and a bigger call cause for her
before the whole olympics started
because then the magnifying glass would
have been on
that exactly right wayne's right yeah
yeah yeah that's true i mean it could
have been in a moment she she didn't get
the score she made she didn't get score
she thought she should have on the first
routine she didn't know that's what she
pulled out if she had a better sleep
with a my pillow then
she would uh run it um what are you
running again in gwinnett
i am not i i i was a delegate before i'd
never be a delegate again
um you know i i have major issues with
the political process
uh just in general um you know
i i'd probably never run for public
office that's the same question doesn't
matter political not political favorite
foods holidays ask us anything just make
sure you put a question mark so we know
it's a question
leah why are these athletes
disrespecting our flags for attention
yeah answer to your own question for
attention they get the more they
disrespect the flag
the more money they make that's to some
extent i'm sure that's right
yeah again it's not money people people
see again
it's it's human nature to an extent
there's there's money out there
deborah
they wearing briefs pink
pink woody are you a democrat what are
you are you a democrat
no i voted for i voted democrat in the
last election
uh i won't lie about it but i am i am
not a democrat i'm an independent i
i i fall i i'll vote for if somebody was
the run
republican that i agreed with enough i'd
vote for them i i
just not the case right now all right
when is pelosi going to be nicola i like
her name
when is uh policy going to be punished
for the lies and corruption never
wow when she dies and goes to hell
damn same as i mean the same as every
other politician abuses their power
uh let's see jerry says does bubble meat
take snap asking for a friend i don't
know
we don't know about that wow that's too
much man
it's too much why if you fly to japan
you must test but to fly
from japan you do not do they test
before you
come from anywhere no i don't think they
are and that's you guys
we where we will get these other
variants we're going to get other
variants from other countries
we probably should shut down all of our
borders can i can i just say across the
board
the hypocrisy is what is suffocating
there's there's there's all these
different mandates and all these
different places
all these different rules and all these
some people slide some people
and i think that's what a lot of people
are just tired of
the hypocrisy i like along this question
because i just learned something about
this i did like
i watched a seminar on this how long do
you think we have before the government
takes over and puts us in camps now
listen i just watched
an entire episode on what's called
shielding that um
some far left liberal came out with
and what they want to do is shield
they're not saying in camps but they
would like to have like specific homes
that
shield people that all have like
autoimmune
deficiencies and put them all in the
same house and then you would have very
little contact with the outside world
and they said that they would like to
try to maybe even have a commune where
you put all the
uh elderly over 65 in the community and
then they have
very little contact with the outside
world they get their food delivering to
them
it's a new word no no no
it's a new word but it's already been
done building it's already been done
yeah retirement house it was done in
1913 it was done in 1936.
underground in germany
do you think trump vice president will
be
running with him we you know what
we're talking about
right who do you think trump's running
mate
will be you got 30 seconds
hurry up and put it in the thing because
you're
saying that trump runs whether you're in
the camp that he doesn't run or you're
in the camp that he does run
saying i guarantee he's running just say
he's already on the ballot
he's running who is or who should be his
running mate he's running
ivanka ivanka should be his running mate
yeah i'm going to start with him let me
say this right now
the only trump i think that could win an
election right now is
what i i do i do i think she's like
she's not that i don't like it
she's a great person to talk to she's
very likely in person
but when she's in public on the stage
like that
she's got she's got a mature she's got
money i i think
i think that's why i think you run her
as a vice president
bring her along let me do this she's
better than that
yeah yeah you know what honestly
honestly y'all
look can candace candace
is not going to be the vice presidential
nominee wait don't get mad at it i mean
that's just their thoughts it's just
wrong
i know i know i know but i mean we're
trying to be serious here that's all
i mean
you can't run you can't run
two people from the same state
okay so see folks we've been talking a
lot about this behind yes
yeah and i don't think many of y'all
realize this
um donald trump's state
he changed his residence to florida
correct
yeah yeah tax purposes and this great
idea yeah exactly
there is there's a what is it amendment
it's an amendment 12th amendment of the
electoral college
you cannot have two people from the same
state run on a presidential ticket
don't they be representatives of that
state i mean you can
you can but the electorals can't vote
for that vice president then they have
to use their electorals just for the
president
yeah but we don't really vote for the
vice president i mean it used to be what
vice president was literally voted for
in the second well
right and it was the opposite party that
the loser actually got second place
second place
vice president hey i'm i'm all for that
one too
listen listen republicans and this
and this is to everybody out there that
is listening right now
not once in our american history
have we had two people from the same
state
on the same ticket for president of the
united states
because change changed to
reason why you don't because
the country will see it as uh
um you know as brian you
you said yesterday in the text um
you want to have a well-rounded campaign
yeah yeah you want somebody yeah north
south
from one side right to be able to to
to to talk to the whole whole country
yeah but i think you're outside of that
with trump i mean again because he is
we did say that we did something outside
of that
we did say that with him but he was new
york pence
was middle america with indiana yeah
it was midwest okay now bush george w
bush was texas
now cheney was taxed at two but then he
wouldn't be moving to montana yeah
yeah dick is way up there in the north
and
why do you say that like that what's his
name his name is dick
it's richard no it's not it's your thing
but even back but even back in the in
the old days
uh you had kennedy that wasn't from
massachusetts
and you had um johnson who was in texas
uh yeah i mean it's it's so it's
supposed to be
well-rounded you don't put every
all your uh all your eggs in one basket
from
one state you don't do that so that's
why a lot of people thought that bottom
and picked klobuchar
was to try to counteract pence for the
mid you know midwest
trump is from new york but he changed
his residence back
on when he changed his residence to
florida now
if he change now if he changes it back
now i've heard
things that he might change it to new
jersey
if he does that he needs to hang up and
do it but
will he be seen as a carpet bagger if he
does that though
uh it's very well could be i mean the
left is gonna bring it up
yeah they will bring it up especially if
you pick but
i will say i have not thrown away
nikki haley and i know some people might
not like her
but trump does trump really likes nikki
haley
she checks her out that's so disturbing
she checked a lot of boxes
and she is trump as a female
because what she did with the u.n i have
never seen a u.s
ambassador she wiped him up yes she
wiped the floor with all of those
leaders yeah i mean they had so much
respect for her
but she you ain't but she uh
was
i don't know i i see on the show the gop
missed a huge opportunity of creating
candidates that followed trump's
template
and how to win elections with nikki
nikki followed his template on how to
deal with
foreign leaders and that's why they
were like oh they've been able to walk
over other foreign leaders
not with her they didn't walk on over
her because
all she had to do was say what trump
wanted her to say or
they ain't listening what you want me to
do
we should we're not paying y'all
uh we're not paying though we're done
i'm up we're out mic drop
now people say though that a lot of the
times the vice president really doesn't
have any influence on how they vote
so is it a new world though that's a
good question right
does it have more influence now than it
ever has well no 81 million votes for
joe biden and kamala harris
how many votes you think kamala swayed
all 81 million
i mean just the dominion the dominion
her husband's got baptized to china
that's a fact no of course
mypillar.com ladies and gentlemen
mypillar.com
go there check it out you have all
weekend to do it i want you to get
something from my pillow and then i want
you to let us know what you get
or what you got on monday okay um
whether it's the mattress topper whether
it's slippers
these awesome slippers i'm i'm wearing
them today i don't even really think i'd
even take them off too much
uh these awesome slippers uh whatever it
is the pillow
again the mattress topper comes with
pillows so you get a two
two for one thing the weighted blankets
the uh
the the bed that um the
the uh the usb
wayne said he wants you to look at that
all weekend i also have homework for you
i want you to take a look at your bed i
want you to take a look at your grungy
sheets
your old flat pillow that you have your
your
dirty comforter your mattress that's
indented and stained maybe yellow
take a look at what you're saying
what you're sleeping on that's gross
go in your bedroom after the show and
take a look at what you're sleeping on
if it sounds anything like that you need
to get to mypillow.com
and treat yourself because you're
sleeping in a cesspool of your own germs
and dust and it's time to get softer
sheets fluffier pillows
and a nicer comforter and you're going
to use the code word wayne
and then you're going to have a great
weekend
damn okay that's how you that's how you
do it
cbdlion.com for oh
thank you beverly for getting the sheets
she's she's ordered the sheets with your
code word way thank you beverly thank
you so much
thank you this this also helps out the
wayne dupree show
if we get an awesome amount of sales i'm
i'm just putting it out there if we get
awesome amount of sales
from my pillow they're going to give us
our own little
button on my pillow that's a huge
achievement you know oh yeah
achievement we get our own button on my
pillow
and then whatever savings or discounts
or
um specials that they run it's partic
specifically for the wayne dupree
audience what do i do this one great
entertainment
if we have a huge august
why don't we do a my pillow nighttime
show brought to you by my pillow a
two-hour nighttime show
yeah a two hour they want a two-hour
show anyways let's say
in september we have a big 22 hour
nighttime show
in our jammies with our my pillows and
our slippers
we'll do a pajama show a nighttime show
two hours
we'll talk about it like that we'll talk
about jimmy
really in our jammies
yes look look do you want this to be big
or not
they want us in our pajamas they want us
with our my pillows and they want a
two-hour show
on you guys can pick the night but we
gotta have a blowout
on the my pillows so that's the deal
we'll give you a two-hour show in our
pajamas
look at everybody talking about it great
idea great idea
love the jammies they're going to be in
their jammies with us love that idea
we'll have wine and jammies listen it's
going to be a big august holy crap
they're gonna do it they're gonna do it
look at those responses
i i told you listen i i know our
audience
i love our audience leah is gonna have
stalkers after that show
well yeah i don't know what i'm gonna
wear maybe a little teddy
don't be a party pooper brian ryan's
thing brian always does that
two hours that's right
[Laughter]
they like this all right well two hours
two hours they're chanting it i can hear
them chanting it
cbdline.com four slash wayne dupree do
you wear jammies
i guess i have to get me some jammies
okay theresa
hugh hefner that's that's nice kathy if
you want three hours then you better
talk all your audience friends into
having a huge
august on for my pillow yeah we gotta
have a huge argument
audience for that one but no um cbd and
actually
august is i want y'all to know one thing
about august and many of you don't
realize it
um i don't know if y'all know this by
fridays too on fridays at 5 p.m
the media that the white house always
does a dump
of news uh because the most people go
home for the weekend
so most your major people in news go
home
they really can't cover it so a whole
lot of stuff that they
try to sneak under table they sneak it
out at 5 p.m
on friday afternoon well in august
august is the one month in the year
where there is
virtually no news i don't know
i don't know notice that or not they go
on recess too
the house and congress goes on recess
what what the media tries to do is they
try to develop some type of stories
racist or whatnot that will last for a
couple weeks
in august watch out for that okay well
then i guess we'll have a good two-hour
show after we have a blow out my pillow
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah cbdlion.com free
great savings codename wayne
if you purchase something oh from now
and between now and sunday
let us know so that we can give you a
shout out on monday
okay please these are great sponsors cbd
line
and also my pillow they are great
sponsors they're great american
companies and they care about
us the american people and we care about
them and that's why we're promoting
their products
so cbd lion forward slash wayne dupree
hopefully we'll have them on in august
uh
and you know we'll we're getting the
pajama party thing going
uh two hours and it's not even an
election that
that's the thing it's not even an
election but they want to see
us oh come on brian
hey you can wear the pajama bunny outfit
from a christmas story since you're in
near cleveland
[Music]
what how many people you cleaned
i wasn't wait where was the uh show
taking place
the christmas store they were they yeah
they were actually filmed in cleveland
the christmas story
bonnie suit he's in ohio yeah
yeah same thing yeah cleveland ohio i
mean it's one of the things
brian will wear the pink bunny suit if
you have a blowout on my pillow oh i
want to see that that's
that's that's not true what is going on
i do not eat green eggs and ham i do
[Music]
room
okay